después del día de acción de gracias los
estadounidenses esperan con ansias el
black friday fecha en la cual las marcas
en el país ofrecen grandes descuentos
sobre sus productos la tradición está
tan arraigada que cientos de personas
empiezan a hacer fila desde la noche
anterior para ser los primeros en entrar
a las tiendas sin embargo este año por
la pandemia del coronavirus se cree que
la mayoría de personas harán sus compras
de manera virtual más clientes van a
comprar por internet este año y
típicamente el black friday y el ciber
man day son nuestros picos de venta así
que esperamos que sea mucho más este año
y estamos realmente preparados y es que
se cree que los estadounidenses seguirán
las recomendaciones de las autoridades
sanitarias en cuanto a no fomentar las
aglomeraciones evite asistir a eventos
de alta aglomeración con baja
ventilación y personas que no
pertenezcan a su hogar en medio de una
crisis económica que ha dejado unos 20
millones de desempleados analistas
indicaron que los estadounidenses
gastarán 160 mil millones de dólares
durante el último trimestre del año lo
que representa 1
5 más comparado con 2019 y que indica
que lo que la población se ahorro en
salidas y entretenimiento durante la
pandemia lo invertirá en compras
navideñas